thiam ministre s'il vous plaît la parole
est à monsieur olivier marc l'ex car si
monsieur le président à chaque premier
ministre c'est l'honneur de la france
d'avoir proclamé en 1789 que nul ne
pouvait être inquiété pour ses opinions
même religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestation ne trouble pas l'ordre
public
c'est l'honneur de la france d'avoir
bâti la grande mosquée de paris sur
nommage à nos compatriotes musulmans
morts pour la france durant la grande
guerre
c'est l'honneur de la france et des
français d'avoir accepté depuis trente
ans que se normalise l'exercice d'un
culte musulman qui est celui de
plusieurs millions de nos compatriotes
mais monsieur le premier ministre la
république peut-elle tolérer aujourd'hui
que des petits groupes extrémistes
véhicule muni d'une idéologie de rupture
avec nos valeurs de rejet de notre
civilisation comment la république
peut-elle relever le défi de
l'intégration si elle n'a se propager au
coeur même de nos quartiers
un discours de rejet de cette idée même
d'intégration à la communauté nationale
en france il n'y a pas d'autorité
musulmane suprême pour défendre cette
conception apaisée de l'islam qui est
celle de tant de pays amis maroc algérie
turquie tunisie
c'est donc aux autorités de la
république qui doit bien d'agir et de
dire ce qui est acceptable et ce qui ne
l'est pas sur le sol de notre république
il ne s'agit pas de diviser il s'agit au
contraire de rassembler tous les
français
nos compatriotes musulmans attendent
aussi cela de nous parce que les
musulmans sur les premières victimes de
cette radicalité hier au koweit
mais aussi au quotidien de notre pays
parce qu'on tolérante où on ne sent
jamais rien distinguer nous laissons la
place à tous les amalgames
alors monsieur le premier ministre à la
tunisie vient de prendre une mesure
extrêmement forte
la fermeture de 80 mosquées salafistes
elle pourrait vous inspirer au delà des
grands mots quels actes votre
gouvernement va-t-il enfin poser pour
défendre cette valeur qui est aussi
notre devise la fraternité et ne plus
laisser en paix ceux qui la combattent
vous nous parlez de guerre et vous avez
raison mais agissez en conséquence et
cesser de vous battre seulement avec des
mots la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député marc l'ex votre
question appelle des réponses très
précises
d'abord pour ce qui concerne l'expulsion
des imams des prêcheurs de haine qu en
est il
je vais vous donner des chiffres nous
avons depuis 2012 procéder à l'expulsion
de 40 prêcheurs de haine ou iman vite
autoproclamés qui appelait et provoqué
au terrorisme voilà ce que nous avons
fait il n'y a pas un département à 1 au
sein duquel nos services ou les préfets
nous apporte des éléments témoignant de
cette dérive où nous n'agissons pas je
tiens d'ailleurs à vous dire que pour la
même période précédente entre 2007 et
2012 ce sont 15 expulsion pour sont
intervenus en cinq ans là où en l'espace
de trois ans nous en avons fait car ans
on peut toujours demander plus monsieur
marc l'ex mais je vous donne une réponse
extrêmement précise et par département
je suis prêt parce que je rends toujours
compte devant la représentation
nationale de ce qu'est l'action des
services du ministère de l'intérieur à
vous faire un bilan extrêmement précis
et vous constaterez que le gouvernement
n'a sur ce sujet qu'une démarche et une
seule c'est la fermeté deuxième point
vous parlez des mosquées pour ce qui
concerne les mosquées nous sommes dans
un état de droit et je pense que nul ici
ne considère qu'il faut revenir sur nos
principes constitutionnels ni sur nos
principes qui nous lie à l'union
européenne et le droit nous dit un
comportement les imams autoproclamés qui
profèrent là elles doivent être expulsés
ils le sont de ceux qui commettent des
infractions pénales doivent être
poursuivis ils sont systématiquement
poursuivis parce que les préfets porte
plainte
au titre de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale 3 lorsque des
associations qui gèrent des mosquées
salafistes dans la globalité de leurs
membres appellent à la haine ces
associations ont vocation à être
dissoute dans la maîtrise et le respect
du droit
c'est ce que fait le ministère de
l'intérieur et nous sommes actuellement
alors que cela n'a jamais été fait en
france a procédé à l'examen des cas qui
nous sont signalés pour pouvoir avec la
plus grande fermeté procéder à la
dissolution
donc ne faisons pas sur ce sujet de
polémique